the webcam I'm currently using is so bad
I'm sorry I don't know what's wrong with
it I am as in Focus as I can be and even
when I up the saturation to the maximum
amount it's just like washed out and
blurred I'll swap it back to my old
webcam mistakes have been made I'll do
it tomorrow I swear in unrelated news
twitch has updated its uh approach to
sexual content and content
classification labels people are of
course up in arms the article goes over
some specific terms and details and
States we have received consistent
feedback from streamers that our current
policies around sexual content are
confusing and that it can be difficult
to know how their content will be
interpreted based on these policies and
they have a little FAQ that highlights
some previously prohibited but now
allowed with label content uh this is a
hilarious sentence to have to read
content that deliberately highlighted
breasts products or pelvic region even
when fully clothed was previously
prohibited and is now allowed with label
streamers found it difficult to
determine what was prohibited and what
was allowed and often evaluating whether
or not the Stream violated this portion
of the policy was subjective which Fair
It also says fictionalized drawn
animated or sculpted fully exposed
female presenting breasts and or
genitals or bodu regardless of gender
used to be prohibited and is now allowed
there is a thriving artist community on
Twitch and this policy was overly
punitive and did not reflect the impact
of the content now this one is one that
I like am oh my God I'm so out of focus
that I just can't do anything about it
it's so weird I don't think the outrage
is Justified in this particular instance
for this section we'll get to latter
sections this is basically saying that
you're allowed to sculpt or Draw titties
without getting banned and I just so
often see the like it's for children
thing thrown around where twitch is
concerned but children also go to
museums where you see sculptures or
reneissance paintings that have titties
and genitals like full frontal genitals
people have seen the statue of David
like at least a picture of it by the
time they're 10 when you learn about
ancient Egypt in primary school I don't
remember what they call that in other
countries what do they call primary
school you know the the school when when
you're like when you're a child you not
a teenager yet I don't know what you
call it in America we call it Primary
School M you will see depictions of
genitalia in artwork so that makes
perfect sense to me though I still
immediately go okay but like to what
extent is that allowed like are we just
allowing like full hanai type art now
these two um are a little spicier so
previously you were not allowed to have
body writing on female presenting
breasts and or buttox regardless of
gender and you previously weren't
allowed erotic dancers that involve
disturbing or disturbing gestur such as
strip teasers and I guess now you can
just do that popular dances such as
twerking grinding and pole dancing are
now allowed with a label previously some
dances were prohibited and others were
allowed with a label enforcing on Dances
regardless of context me our policy
prohibited twerking at a wedding okay
it's really specific or taking a pole
dancing exercise class for example the
policy now takes context into
consideration and only prohibits
streaming inside of an adult
entertainment establishment and now as
long as attire requirements are met body
painting on breasts and buttocks is
allowed with the sexual themes label so
I think the sexual themes label is a
very smart idea here's the reality here
sex cells this occurs across all
Industries there's obviously a vibrant
live streaming scene in the adult
entertainment industry and twitch as a
big company likes money you know hot
take Amazon likes money and so long as
the streamers actually follow the
guidelines and go sexual themes label
then it should exist in a specific place
you know I've seen countless examples of
people saying oh bikini streams this is
a website for children as well but like
kids go to the beach I wear a bikini at
the beach there are often children
children love beaches kids watch music
videos which have women in bikinis
movies have women in bikinis like it's
like this weird thing where we try to
pretend that twitch is like the kids
channel not saying that kids don't go on
the website but it's just it's just a
weird illogical out I think when the
real world has much worse more explicit
content than twitch does I also feel
like it's just like a little reductive
like are we trying to pretend that
twitch really is just for children like
doesn't that make the whole thing just
so unserious now I will say personally I
don't like that this stuff is on Twitch
when I go on Twitch I don't want to see
this stuff as somebody who does use
twitch to watch people play video games
or talk about video games I do find it
annoying when somebody like half naked
doing a just chatting stream shows up my
homepage or in my recommended channels
that is not the kind of content that I
want it's jarring and it's weird and
it's culturally very strange however as
an adult my stance is to just not look
at it and I feel like that should exist
across the board if you don't like it
just don't look at it just get on out of
there tell twitch not to recommend you
those channels clearly there is a market
for that kind of content just as there's
a market for a bunch of games I'm not
interested in I'm not interested in
watching people play Madden so I
wouldn't watch a Madden video if it was
recommended to me now here's the thing
that I have said before in a video um
when the hot tub controversy popped off
but I just want to repeat it now there
is so often this conversation that's
brought up about how twitch streamers
that are doing anything sexually
explicit make it a lot harder for women
on Twitch who do not do that to exist as
a woman on Twitch who does not do that
and will never do that I mean I'm
wearing a baggy oversized hoodie right
now I most often stream in a trip XL
t-shirt I just want to give my opinion
on that um because in theory you are
trying to defend me you surely you've
seen it like the notion that women who
titty streamers they call them women who
are promoting their only fans on Twitch
are stealing views from all other women
and making it harder for upand cominging
female streamers or for female streamers
in general I just do not believe this to
be true in the same way that I don't
watch Madden streamers people who are
after titilation such a good word on
Twitch are not going to watch me they
are going to watch those streamers and
as the amount of those kinds of
streamers who are posting sexually
fueled clearly sexually seductive
sexually suggestive content has risen
there are more and more and more of them
there has been absolutely zero impact on
my growth as a twitch streamer who does
not do that I am only speaking for
myself here obviously I don't know the
data but in my head it is two separate
audiences there are always going to be
some men on the internet who want that
kind of content and I'm never going to
provide that kind of content so frankly
somebody else serving it to them on a
silver platter is actually better for my
community it gets the horn dogs who've
just seen a woman and like had some
reaction that they can't keep to
themselves at Bay they will go consume
it from that person who is in
intentionally doing that who was
intentionally fostering that community
and leave me in my community alone it is
better for my twitch chat it is not
stealing views from me because I was
never going to get those viewers anyway
as somebody who is effectively not sexy
if anything it's kind of helpful again
this is not a research stance I just
wanted to share how I feel about it as a
very unsexy twitch streamer um just my
personal opinion on that I'm never going
to get those viewers I don't want those
viewers I am very happy for them to go
somewhere else and I have not seen it
negatively impact my streams in any way
whatsoever and here's where it does
become an issue because it does I find
it a little bit frustrating as somebody
who works in video games and would like
video games in general to be taken
seriously as an entertainment medium
that video games aren't allowed to have
nudity the video games your actual
gameplay can't have nudity even though I
would consider that an art form nor can
you have sex scenes but you can have
openly sexually explicit content from an
actual human being why are we excluding
video games here I definitely think that
there should be ratings on streams there
already are obviously you shouldn't be
allowed to view them if you're under a
certain age but penalizing somebody
because a character creator had a penis
or because an RPG with romance elements
had a sex scene why are we allowing it
from real people and not from video
games which again I would argue are
making huge strides in becoming a mature
storytelling medium or an art form I'm
generally in the camp of anti-censorship
right like I think that all things
should be allowed to exist I don't think
that titty streamers should be censored
or women on beaches should be censored I
don't think that that should be censored
I think it should be categorized
accordingly but I'm not I'm not for
censorship in this case and it is kind
of surprising to me the amount of Gamers
who like grow censorship when it comes
to Twitch specifically they would
complain if video games censored
anything sexual or censored anything
violent but they don't have the same
attitude towards twitch it's just a mess
of opinions in general and I would not
be surprised if twitch has made that so
by kind of fumbling and being unclear
and having to change these terms so
frequently and having it still be
unclear I also just always want to ask
people who are like really up in arms
about hot tub streamers or or whatever
what are you actually upset about is it
really kids are you really worried about
children here or do you also have
concerns that these women are stealing
your views because if it's the latter
one again as a woman I would argue you
were never going to get viewers from the
people who are watching those women
anyway that's all I'm saying